all right people we are live here at the
Reagan Library in Simi Valley California
about an hour outside of Los Angeles
that's right Dave Rubin has returned to
the scene returned to California Kami
Cali and I have to tell you the place is
an absolute dump Simi Valley absolutely
beautiful the Reagan Library absolutely
beautiful I haven't been inside yet but
I've been here before it's a truly
gorgeous day out La itself which is
where we're staying and we spent a
couple hours this afternoon uh between
the homeless and the grotesque amount of
dirt and garbage on the streets and all
that stuff you get it but that's not
what I want to really talk about today I
actually am glad to be here obviously uh
Republican debate number two is tonight
uh the shadow that I suppose looms large
is that Donald Trump is not here once
again I'll talk a little bit about that
uh in a few minutes and I kind of want
to go through just like some pre-game
thoughts on each one of the candidates
kind of what they have to do if anyone
else actually has a chance here and kind
of grade what people have done what
they're going to do going ahead uh
interestingly so we're doing this really
uh obviously all on the fly from the
rumble uh Booth right here but all of
the mainstream media booths we're the
only online media Booth here so this is
this is really the future right like
everyone knows it everyone gets it it's
why Rumble has been under assault for
the last week some of the Russell Brand
stuff and everything else it's like I
can say whatever I want here what your
look well you guys can't quite see it
you know we'll post some pictures of it
and we'll take some video but there's
about 20 booths uh just about 15 feet
away from me on the other side of the
street right here of all the mainstream
media outlets and of course you're
getting very overly prepared people we
just scribble a couple things down on a
piece of paper and Phoenix says to me
Dave have at it and we see what happens
right but you're gonna get an honest
assessment as honest as I can possibly
be relative to what's going on here
today and what to expect and all that
but interestingly you might just find
some of this interesting so all the main
uh mainstream Outlets are right here
kellyanne Conway is right over there I'm
not sure who she's working for right now
but Karl Rove is just about 15 feet away
right now he probably can hear me right
now uh he maybe he's working for Fox I
guess these days I would love to know uh
oh we turned a little bit maybe maybe I
would love to know you know Donald Trump
often says that Ron DeSantis is in it
with Karl Rove Ron DeSantis has said
that he met Karl Rove once uh Donald
Trump did work for or Karl Rove did work
for Donald Trump maybe we can get Carl
over here if Carl wants to swing by uh
Brock or one of you guys looks like
Carl's wrapping up if Carl wants to
swing by and say hi that would be great
let's see if we can snag him and come on
by we'll see what happens Phoenix go for
it let's see what happens if he wants to
jump on here we can settle this once and
for all whether Carl Rove is more in it
with Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis uh but
anyway tonight while Phoenix is working
on that he's going right now so we will
we will see if we can grab Karl Rove
right now but while we're doing that the
guys that are here tonight so first off
I just found this out a second ago uh
Doug bergram is here again remember Doug
from the last debate who actually was
pretty decent but he had heard himself
playing basketball like the night before
uh he's here again who knew very
exciting so we'll see what happens with
him uh then we've got The Usual Suspects
uh Chris Christie Mike Pence Nikki Haley
uh Vivek ramaswami Ron DeSantis and Tim
Scott and we will see how everybody does
did we get Karl Rove we got the no
we got to know from Carl what did he say
what did he say
oh he's a Fox News contributor he can't
do the Reuben report on the free
internet but oh oh that's nice to hear
he did give he did give Phoenix a strong
solid handshake all right he's
contractually obligated but in some
respects you guys get it that's sort of
even that little moment right there and
that was obviously completely unscripted
that's sort of the problem right now
between mainstream media and what's
happening online like we can do things
on the Fly it's not scripted I'm not
looking at a teleprompter or anything
else I'm just talking to you as I always
do these guys it's scripted you can only
talk to this person or that person
there's kellyanne Conway over there
we'll see who else CNN is over there I
don't know that guy's name kind of pudgy
asexual guy who is that
the pudgy asexual guy it could be anyone
on CNN who anyway he's over there but
his producer's got a mask on so that's
exciting anywho I want to throw to two
clips actually from things that happened
over the last couple days before we get
fully into the to the debate stuff oh
and by the way we will be live
immediately after the debate uh that'll
be 8 P.M Pacific time which is 11 A.M
eastern time I'll be live right here
with Patrick Bet David and with Larry
Elder uh and Larry Elder was hoping to
be here he's actually in a lawsuit with
the RNC Because he believes that he
actually qualified for the last debate
and they didn't let him in so I thought
he would be the perfect guest for this
uh so the two of them will join me for a
half hour then pbd uh is heading back to
the free state of Florida Carol
Markowitz from the New York Post is
going to join us and we'll see who else
uh shows up my God it's Robert Barnes
Robert Barnes from viva bar in law is
here Robert you want to wave to the
camera you want to wave to the camera's
right there you can wave to the people
on Rumble no you have to you have to get
in the frame of the camera look at look
at this guy he's gonna wave wave to the
people how you doing brother good to see
you good to see you wave to the people
there you go there you go what do you
think is going to happen tonight in
under 30 seconds
DeSantis needs a big win are you in
frame are you in frame let's see let's
see there you go here we go all right
Barnes is taking a seat my God we do
everything on the Fly here you know what
let me handle the uh
I'm gonna handle the two clips that we
were gonna throw to and then Barnes is
gonna join me for some analysis how
about that yeah oh and viva's here too
and after the whole crew oh and Viva wow
viva's live streaming on locals while
we're live streaming on Roblox all right
you know what let me do the two clips
real quick and then we'll get to uh to
Robert over here so the two clips I
wanted to show you one of them is uh
fauci in the last day or two has really
been going hard on DeSantis and
basically he has been saying that
DeSantis by criticizing him and as you
know if you criticize this anthis that
means you're criticizing science if you
criticize this at this you're basically
calling for violence against him so
let's throw to clip one
as I say on the right in a kind of
unhinged dangerous manner I just want to
play you something that Ron desandes
said about you last year have a listen
right
and I'm just sick of seeing him I know
he says he's gonna retire someone needs
to grab that little elf and Chuck him
across the Potomac
I mean I have to ask do you consider
that to be a threat from the governor of
Florida because to me it looks like he's
inciting violence I wonder what your
reaction is when you hear someone saying
you should be attacked well you know
it's a complicated issue but I have
become
by people who know nothing about me who
don't investigate what I've said I've
been done I become the symbol of what
the far right extremists feel that I'm
the one who had to in an uncomfortable
way I wasn't pleased with that I wasn't
happy to do it that I had to publicly
disagree with the president of the
United States that was very painful for
me because I have a great deal of
respect for the presidency of the United
States but I felt in order to just
maintain my own personal and
professional integrity and my
responsibility to the American public I
had to say it like it was and I had to
do it publicly that triggered a degree
of negativity towards me on the part of
the far right that all of a sudden when
you have anger in some cases maybe
justifiable anger of one ideological
group against the other you need a
symbol like somebody has got to be the
object it's not just crazy I mean that's
a man who wants to be
what happens is that if you become the
symbol of of of the object of people's
anger even people who know nothing about
you know the fact that in my career I've
been involved in Saving literally
millions of lives that people hello you
know forget that is that I become that
symbol and then when they say something
like that you get somebody who doesn't
know anything at all about me who's
Crazy says wow I'm gonna go get that
person or that person should be killed
all right so I believe I said stoking
violence against DeSantis thank you my
lawyer over here was correcting me on
that uh but fauci saying that DeSantis
is stoking violence against him and that
he saved millions of lives uh Robert
you're a pretty factual guy I don't
think there's any evidence that fauci
actually saved millions of lives is
there have you seen that study and
especially now that we're finding out
today that he was secretly in cahoots
with the CIA to cover up the fact that
he was complicit in the origin of this
virus to begin with that took millions
of lives so either took or I mean just
talked to all the people that are
vaccine injured the reason I really
wanted to show you that clip you guys
know my feelings about fauci obviously
but I want to show you that clip because
it's this constant ratcheting up of the
rhetoric and we're going to hear a lot
of rhetoric in the building behind me
tonight and uh although I did not have a
plan on having you on the show I mean
rhetoric you're you're a showman type I
always think you're you're like the
lawyer showman that's how I sort of
frame you in my mind what do you think
has to happen tonight in terms of
rhetoric with these guys to to change or
what do you think just generally about
bouchi first in fact he's a criminal who
wants to escape the responsibilities in
account I mean he's a criminal at every
level he was a criminal because he's
responsible for why covid-19 ever
existed because of his complicity and
continuing to do illicit bioweapon
research through China and then covering
it up and lying to the world about it
now we know the Intel CIA whistleblowers
are disclosing this then he compounded
that with all of his erratic sporadic
orders do a mess don't do a math do a
math don't do a mask uh dance milgram's
live Milgram experiment routine which
millions of people are injured and died
around the world on top of the
depression on top of the lost wages on
top of all the disaster he did with AIDS
this guy has been one disaster after the
other after the other and these probably
you know we're here Reagan Library
Reagan's greatest regret is seeing what
fauti turned out to be instead of being
the good Italian uh American Boy from
New York he ended up being a corrupt
Hollywood style you know you know I'm
very sympathetic to the Brooklyn accent
I'm from Brooklyn I'm sympathetic to the
old school Brooklyn accent but all right
you know before we get into what's gonna
happen behind us in a couple hours let
me throw to one other clip because there
was this viral moment a couple days ago
on the Patrick bad David podcast and as
I mentioned Patrick will be joining me
for the post game after this but he had
Carrie Lake on and she was criticizing
DeSantis over locking down beaches and
forcing mandates and masks and vaxes uh
and this thing really really went viral
uh we then edited a little something
that she's probably not thrilled with uh
it's a quick hit you'll see
let us not forget that DeSantis also
shut the beaches down DeSantis took a
page out of Gavin newsom's Playbook
despite what he says he shut the beaches
down hold up wait a minute something
ain't right we don't want them Gathering
and I see they do gather including on
beaches and including in restaurants
young all right all right so we
obviously added in Trump calling for
DeSantis to close beaches as Carrie Lake
was saying that the Santa's closed
beaches desantises did not denying that
the first few weeks he did some things
that he regrets uh so this is actually
perfect that we have you here because we
actually like each other we have no
problem doing shows together but you're
on the Trump side of this thing I'm on
the DeSantis side of this thing my
frustration I I know that Trump was a
very good president and if he's the
nominee I'm going to vote for him my
frustration has been the lying around
covid and Florida what Carrie was doing
there that somehow DeSantis wasn't the
best governor in the nation I guess some
people could say maybe it was uh
Christie gnome but like that that what
we know to be true from two years ago
seems to be flipped on its head do you
think that's a fair criticism coming
from someone that the Trump guy I mean I
think as a whole everybody I was
unsatisfied with everybody's response to
covet sure some were better or worse at
Key junctures and DeSantis was
particularly good in 2021-4 I thought I
thought he was good Midway through 2020
to the end and then 2021 Ford when he
brought in a great Surgeon General
that's when I thought he really he did
well and what I would love like if I was
in DeSantis Camp I'm the governor I got
I got control other people don't the
he's opened up a state grand jury into
whether Pfizer lied to the people but
the moderna lie to the people of Florida
yeah I mean I agree with you that his
best argument is how he handled covet go
in and do that grand jury expose Pfizer
for the criminals that they are maybe
even expose fauci for the criminals he
is yeah and make and put it on Broad
scale that's what I think the scientist
is at his best so when you hear though
Carrie Lake who's obviously a surrogate
who was just here a moment ago or you
hear Trump saying that New York was
better than Florida on covid which is
obviously patently untrue and Trump used
to say it himself do you just kind of
just you just kind of let that go
because that's trumpy and Trump and I
see that as politics of the campaign in
other words efforts to muddy the waters
on each other's record concerning it and
I think there's aspects of desantis's
record that could have been a lot better
on on covet I think those aspects of
Trump's record that could have been a
lot better on coping and that's where my
advice to both camps uh has been focused
on what you can do now now Trump is kind
of a little bit of a buy he can only
talk about what he's going to do so he
can talk about different aspects of
vaccine mandates and reinstatement and
so on and so forth but DeSantis has an
edge that very few candidates have he's
an actual governor use that it was
rather than relitigate 2020 go in and
and say Here's what I'm going to do
right now things that will universally
be appealing to the Republicans and
Independence yeah why don't we do why
don't we do like 20 seconds on each of
the guys so I think we have your
assessment of DeSantis Trump isn't here
would you have liked to seen Trump here
to defend the record to have to putting
aside that I get what the polls say I
had Jordan Peterson on after the last
debate and what he said is in a healthy
democracy you would be debating these
ideas meaning Biden would debate JFK and
Trump would debate DeSantis and the rest
of them I I agree with that well in fact
if the of the one person I think I get
Trump he's he's ahead so he sees no
utility to it and he's got a personal uh
grief uh with Fox yeah so that's really
how I take that but a guy who they
should invite is the guy that Democrats
won't allow debate allow invite Robert
Kennedy why not I mean I get to
Republican debate but add Robert Kennedy
highlighting how Joe Biden is scared to
debate him put him up there I have said
many times I think I said it's rfk's
face himself like he'll basically be a
moderate Republican by the end of this
in essence he is well his father was his
uncle was
I'm going to give you 20 seconds on each
of these guys did you I did not know
that Doug berggrum was even going to be
here but he's back yeah yeah you believe
it what are you making it 20 seconds
yeah I mean uh these candidates are
going nowhere fast in other words if
you're gonna go from one percent to five
percent and somehow be relevant be
significant the way Vivek has you need a
marketing campaign like the back none of
these guys have that's why they're going
nowhere all right so what do you what do
you make of the bank uh I think the back
needs to continue like the Vex in one
advantage over everyone else he doesn't
have to worry about donors so
consequently he can use tonight solely
to talk to voters he needs to boost his
poll ratings he did okay in the first
debate he held his own which is more
than what they expected for a guy doing
his first ever debate but he needs to
step it up if he wants to be that sort
of trump substitute vote if you will for
those people he needs to ramp it up what
do you make of the idea that he's kind
of just running as Celebrity Apprentice
contestant like number two goal is to
one I think he got ticked off about the
walksters coming after him the reality
is he'd probably be chilling out doing
making money on the beach if they
wouldn't if right they harassed him so
he decided screw you guys and now he's
gonna see how much he can get in
politics and he's trying to leverage
this campaign into some future long term
I I think that's a fair assessment Chris
Christie uh Christy's he's got such a
low ceiling I'm cursing this whole thing
is I hate Trump more than anybody I hate
Trump more than anybody I hate Trump
more than anybody and it's like okay we
get it but that gets you to 10 points it
can't get you above 10 points maybe I
think he'd be happy at 10 pence uh pants
you know did better I thought tactically
speaking in otherwise he was aggressive
he was impassioned he he was but you
know how is he going to out uh do Nikki
Haley and DeSantis that that's who he's
competing with for the non-trump vote
yeah and that's because there's a
portion of the vote that's the
anti-trump vote that's through Chris
Christie's trying to monopolize but
that's a very small constituency there's
more of a non-trump book about half the
Republican party is open to voting for
someone else uh and that's who they're
competing for and the and that two pence
really needs to do a lot better with
coming out with how you hate populism I
don't think is the best way to get this
last couple real quick uh Nikki she's
still my dark horse in that she's a pro
is a great governor was a great
Ambassador under Trump at the U.N U.S
ambassador and I think people kind of
generally like her even though I know a
lot of the Trump people really seem to
hate her on foreign policy even though
he was her but she was his Ambassador I
mean I call her neocon Nikki so I'm not
a fan yeah but from a tactical
perspective she did the best of the
first debate got the most confidence of
Voters that were looking for an
alternate to Trump got the most
confidence of donors that are looking
for the alternative to Trump I see
tonight's debate as really DeSantis
versus Nikki Haley in terms of
establishing that next who who deserves
that second level right Santa's had it
he's kind of lost it a little bit Nikki
Haley grabbed it can she continue that
momentum or does she sink backwards and
uh Tim Scott will his girlfriend be here
yeah that and Kenny talk louder I mean
the things I mean and my god Patrick
about David the whole internet is here
he'll be with us in a couple hours holy
cow the I mean it you know someone just
to be at least a little bit more
entertaining and engaging I mean that
that love uh you know that you can't do
that in debate yeah did I get through
everybody that's uh
what a lame-o God bless teachers God
bless teachers you come to a republican
debate talk about features no I know
teachers or Republicans we hate teachers
yeah why was school teachers suck for
terrible it's a problem in America
Robert Barnes what can we pimp out
vehicles
.locals.com all right thank you my
friend absolutely good to see you good
to see you all right that's what we do
on the Fly you can you can walk across
the camera yeah this is you know this
isn't Network news
live
hey very nice like Biden stumbling uh
after an interview and he doesn't know
that he's supposed to sit there that's
what you get so look obviously Barnes
and I don't see eye to eye on this uh on
this Trump DeSantis thing for sure for
sure I do concede by the way uh that
that Trump is way ahead if polls if
polls have any meaning whatsoever at
this point and and it's really hard to
gauge whether they do remember a big red
wave is coming and then obviously that
didn't happen but Trump is in essence
the incumbent here uh putting aside
numbers for a second I I do agree with
uh the notion that I mentioned from
Jordan Peterson after the uh the last
debate which is that in a healthy
democracy put aside I'm winning you're
losing I don't have to talk to number
two I was the president they stole it
from me I'm being indicted put aside all
of that right put aside every
personality here put aside Trump into
Santa's everything else
to me in a healthy democracy the only
way we will actually ever truly
understand what we are who we are where
we're going what a healthy civilization
should look like would in essence be to
really talk about those ideas and
unfortunately right now because of the
nature of the polls because maybe of the
nature of just how Trump wants to act in
this whole thing or I think to some
degree he's a little afraid to defend
some of his record particularly against
the scientists we're not doing that but
again it doesn't have anything to do
with them you could do the same version
of this on the Democrat side right Joe
Biden has a has a real Challenger right
now in Robert F Kennedy Jr they he's
polling basically a 20 within the party
and for all the problems of the
Republicans and the Republicans have a
whole bunch of problems and the RNC has
a whole bunch of problems in everything
else the DNC is fully rigging this thing
now Biden obviously if he's alive and
walking and they can get him out there
weekend at Bernie style he's going to be
the nominee although I I absolutely am
convinced they're figuring out a way to
to make it be Newsome and Newsome is
supposed to be here by the way today and
I swear to you if he is anywhere near me
I I will try to talk to him on camera
because I I think he is the devil
incarnate but anyway the point is with
the DNC
they are changing the rules as this
whole primary process is going on so
that Robert F Kennedy basically can't
get any votes if any of the candidates
this is a rule that they put into place
RFK has talked about it if any of the
candidates even go to the early primary
States like Iowa for example then the
votes will go to the incumbent go to Joe
Biden because they know Joe Biden
doesn't have to campaign so if RFK goes
there to make his case to the Democrat
voter of Ohio of Iowa they will actually
give those votes to Biden That's How
Deeply corrupt that side is and I
suppose what my point would be is those
of us who are uh not crazy leftists
those of us who are walking away from
the Democrat Party those of us who are
maybe Democrats like rfk's Uncle uh JFK
and those of us that care about America
those of us who are completely
apolitical and everything else uh we
have a chance to be a little bit better
right to actually debate ideas and that
would be my challenge I suppose to
Donald Trump he should be here today
it's as simple as that it does not
matter whether I happen to think
DeSantis is the better choice at this
moment or not or whatever you think
about the specific people like if you
are making your case I'm going to be the
guy that's going to go against Chinese
president XI and I'm going to be the guy
that stands up to Putin and Kim Jong-un
and all of these things that's what I'm
going to be right that I want to be the
leader of this nation right and defend
your constitutional rights and the Bill
of Rights and all of that stuff I think
it's incumbent on you I think that you
have a duty actually to get up there and
defend your ideas and not just you know
occasionally show up at a pizza shop or
or whatever he's been doing lately that
that's my personal take on it but I want
to just go through some of the other
candidates give you my take myself how
long do we have guys
got about 13 minutes so I'll try to do
I'll try to do two or three minutes on
on each of them I'll hold uh I'll hold
DeSantis to the end uh so Nikki I really
think is the Dark Horse right now now I
I I've interviewed her several times I
like her personally uh I disagree with
her on the foreign policy stuff I do
believe that you have to carry it speak
softly and carry a big stick but this
idea of really just endlessly pouring
more money into Ukraine and keeping this
war non-war going and funding it like
the average American is just over it we
did a story on the show the other day
we've given them that last check it was
something like 116 billion for now all
sorts of other things that have nothing
to do with military for buying grain and
working with their farmers and
infrastructure and funding all housing
projects like a whole bunch of stuff and
it's like if we are at War then declare
war but I don't want to be at War and by
the way if we were at war with them you
know Putin's got nukes and do you want
to be at war with a guy with nukes
because then we're basically in World
War three so I think she has to clean up
some of the uh foreign policy stuff to
make to get any sort of inroad with the
base but I think I think the average
voter looks at her and says there's a
pretty successful governor of South
Carolina she was U.S ambassador to the
U.N under Trump she's well spoken she's
bright she has a Clear Vision like I
think a lot of that plays even if it
doesn't play for like the internet
portion of this so so we'll see what she
does tonight I would say Pence
the problem with Pence is that it's a
little bit hard to figure out what year
he's running and right I always say he
comes across as a caricature on The
Simpsons of a generic Republican in
1994. uh it seems to me he's running
sort of to disassociate himself from
Trump in January 6th and everything else
like to maybe clean up his image and his
legacy a little bit but truly I have
never in in all these events that I go
to and all the people that I talk to and
hear from on the show and all sorts of
I've never said heard from anyone who
has said I I'm supporting Mike Pence he
has the vision that I believe in for the
future so I think he's maybe got one or
two more debates in him uh just maybe
because of you know some level of
institutional money or something like
that but I just don't see any real
support there uh Chris Christie I think
I think barnes's take on Christy was
right I mean he's running just to bash
Trump right Chris Christie nobody thinks
he already tried this right and he lost
last time again it's a little bit of the
Pence thing like there there's no like
group of people that are like Chris
Christie has the vision for the country
and the future that makes sense like
there's just no there's no real support
there these and by the way this is how
politics works you get people on stages
on these stages who are there for a
series of other reasons which would
bring me to someone like vivec and I
think Barnes actually that was a pretty
freaking brutally honest answer right
there that vivec in essence is not
really running for president right now
because if he was running if you were
running for president right now if you
were any of these guys on this stage and
you're running for president you got to
go after Trump you have to become the
nominee and Vivek is always uh defending
Trump and he's always going after
DeSantis so it doesn't quite make sense
there but I think what he's doing is
brand building a lot of people say he
wants to be a senator from Ohio I I have
no idea what his intentions are in that
regard but I think he's he's built
himself into something that people know
and I think it's been quite effective
online so I absolutely give him credit
for that for whatever differences uh we
might have Tim Scott also I would put in
that in that Pence bucket that Christy
bucket where's the real support I've
interviewed him I think he's a decent
human being and I think he's a good
Senator and I think he really loves this
country I I don't think the tone quite
works I think it's a little too soft and
and preachery perhaps
um but I but either way I just don't see
the support then we got Doug bergram is
it bergram it's bergram Bergman
bergum bur gum the fact that I don't
know how to pronounce his name and I
just asked three other people in the biz
and nobody was quite sure God bless the
guy ah
oh and his leg is better than last time
so that's fantastic I mean he heard
himself playing basketball I'm
sympathetic to that but like and I
actually thought he did a pretty decent
job he he actually defended the
Constitution he defended limited
government he had one or two bad moments
related to teachers unions but like this
thing ain't happening Doug I'm sorry and
I'd be happy to sit down with you uh
maybe afterwards because I think this
thing's wrapping up tonight uh who else
did I miss did I miss anyone else
besides DeSantis
got everybody but DeSantis I think I got
Christy we got vivec we got Pence we got
Nikki we got bergam we took all right so
DeSantis so here's the deal with this oh
we and we just did Tim Scott that's it
okay so look here's the deal with
DeSantis
guys I've obviously as a Floridian as
someone that moved two companies a dozen
people
to Florida during covid and has seen
what this guy has done to the State of
Florida and done in terms of our
economic growth and the the growth of
law enforcement we bring in the best of
the best now from the NYPD in Chicago
these officers who don't want to work
there anymore we give them bonuses to
move down to Florida the infrastructure
that we're building in Florida like no
income tax all of those things a super
majority that that is making Florida the
strongest nation in the country right
this was a state that was blue that was
purple that was red like it was kind of
all over the place it is the reddest of
the red right now and everything's
working there right that's why there's
so much fire on him it's not just Trump
from one side it's the Democrats from
the other side it's Newsom it's MSNBC
it's fauci everybody it's it's this
that's why this election is so bizarre
everyone in a weird way is going after
DeSantis uh and yet I I don't deny that
there is probably some validity to the
polls right now DeSantis is going to
every County in Iowa 99 counties so look
if if
the election which the first primary
guys don't forget it's still about five
months away January
that thing happens that first Primary in
Iowa that thing happens and if it's not
Trump all the polls everything that
we've all been screaming about it all
disappears overnight which is why I keep
telling everybody calm down relax take a
breath patience I I believe in doing the
work on the ground and I do see the
scientists doing that that being said I
am not pollyannaish he's got to make
some major moves I think one of the
things that he's suffering from is
something that I coined on the show a
week or two ago I think he's suffering
from Tim Duncan syndrome and Tim Duncan
syndrome is you guys for those of you
that are basketball players Tim Duncan
was amazing power forward on the Spurs
for about 15 years I think he was a
15-time All-Star five-time NBA champion
multiple MVPs multiple finals MVPs all
NBA all the time nobody really remembers
him you never see a highlight reel of
Tim Duncan nobody ever really talks
about the guy he was he lived in a time
of Kobe of Shaq of major shiny Hollywood
stars and doesn't that feel a little bit
like DeSantis he's out they're doing the
work every single day what is the
biggest and I welcome this in the
comments and anywhere else that you guys
can can get us what would be the biggest
criticism you have of him now I see from
the Trump people it's that he's he's
running too early and he's not backing
Trump
okay I suppose that is a type of
criticism uh but what is the criticism
on policy actually if anything if you're
if you're a true conservative if you're
if you were I would say more
conservative than even me I would have a
criticism of him which is that the
15-week abortion ban that we had in
Florida I think was just fine he's moved
it to six weeks now that would work for
the base that that wants that six-week
heartbeat bill that Trump is not Trump
called it I believe his quote was he
called it horrible uh just a week or so
ago with Maria Bartiromo so these was
that was it Maria or it might have been
Brett Bear that one there's a lot of
interviews these days anyway all of the
policy stuff aside and everything else
what clearly DeSantis needs is he needs
some kind of zeitgeist moment he needs
something to kind of capture the
imaginations it's an unfortunate reality
I suppose we live in a time where
competency and doing a good job and
making sure that the security State or
the banks or big Pharma he's doing all
the work to keep them out of your life
as much as possible more than any other
public official that I've ever seen uh
but maybe that isn't enough you have to
capture some level of imagination right
what is Trump better at doing than
anyone maybe maybe literally in world
history he has captured the imagination
of this base that we always talk about
and they think he is the savior now the
question is is he competent when he's
doing it well he did a lot of good
things but the swamp did did take him
out in essence and he believes the
election was stolen well if you believe
the election was stolen even if you're
up by 50 points why wouldn't they steal
it again you really have to think about
that like these are all the things that
you I think you have to have an honest
assessment an honest look at you think
well who could Trump surround himself
with he's gone off on everybody that's
ever worked for him so who can he bring
in to drain the swamp this time uh
DeSantis has shown he has said I mean
and again correct me in the comments
give me one policy that DeSantis didn't
set out to do say I'm going to do this
I'm going to get woke out of schools I'm
going to fight Disney we're gonna get
ESG out of our Florida institutions and
banking all of these things
uh and he's done all of them so that's
the calculation for everybody and I get
it we may not live in a time when people
want the most functional thing they
might want the show right I I one of the
phrases that I mentioned on the show all
the time kfabe right
k-a-y-f-a-b-e-k fade k-fabe is the
concept of professional wrestling Andre
the Giant Hulk Hogan Jake the Snake
Roberts Jimmy Superfly snooka the idea
that you would watch this fake reality
and we'd all be watching and it was
scripted but we'd be having human
emotions about it and we're sort of all
in the show right now and I think we
have a chance maybe to fix this thing
with some competency and decency uh but
all of that being said I'm psyched to go
in there I want to hear from these guys
we'll see if I can get if I can get any
of them for some on-the-fly interviews
and I would say more importantly than
anything else even if you would disagree
with everything I've said here uh I I
hope that you guys can see you know
there's there's a lot of what one man
called what one orange man used to call
fake news over there right there's a lot
of like pre-packaged stuff with people
that are just reading scripts for
corporate stations and everything else
but then there's this whole other thing
happening online whether it's because
you watch me or you watch Crowder or
Rogan or Russell Brand or Glenn
Greenwald or whatever the equivalence on
the other side are a bunch of people
that are trying to roughly figure it out
and figure out a way for a country of
about 350 million people to to be a
little bit better than it is and and
stop this ever encroaching government
from from taking from some and giving to
others and injecting you with things and
everything else I think we can all agree
that maybe we have different ideas of
who should be running that show or how
we get there or anything else then we
can kind of fix some things so hopefully
we'll hear some good ideas tonight about
fixing some things that will be my goal
uh and once again we will be live
immediately after with Patrick Bet David
with Larry Elder who as I said is suing
the RNC because they didn't let him at
the last debate Carol Markowitz from the
New York Post we'll see if any special
guests come and you never know who's
gonna walk on at the Reuben report
where's car there's Karl Rove again Rove
is just one he's roving around you see
what I did there okay guys we'll see you
later thanks